كشفت نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
بحسب قناه فوكس نيوز عن تساوي المقاعد
التي حصل عليها الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون
في مجلس الشيوخ بثمانيه واربعين مقعدا لكل
حزب مع بقاء اربع الولايات لم تحسن بعد
هذه الولايات هي واستانسن اريزونا جورجيا
ونفادا وتعد الانتخابات في جورجيا ونفادا
هي الاصعب والتي قد تحدده هي الحزب الفائز
في مجلس الشيوخ حيث يتقدموا في جورجيا
السنه ترى الديمقراطيه الحاليه على
الجمهوريه هيرشال ووكر ولكن بنسبه بسيطه
واكدت سلطات ان الانتخابات قد تتجه
للاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر المقبل في
هذه الولايه اما في ولايه نيفادا فيتقدموا
الجمهوري ادم لاكسالات على السنه
تردمقراطيه الحاليه كاثرين كورتيز مصر
بنحو 25000 بصوت اي بفارق النقطتين مئتين
اما على صعيد الانتخابات مجلس النواب
فكشفت فوكس نيوز على حصول الجمهوريين على
199 مقعدا
حصلت ديمقراطيون على 174 مقعدا حتى الان
ولا يزال هناك 64 مقعدا لم يتم تحديد
الفائزين بها